Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Denise RQ
Grazie mille!
Bravissimo, mi è piaciuta
molto la presentazione
ma non vi ha detto la cosa
più importante:
ve ne sete accorti, sono non vedente.
Questo è fondamentale per voi
perché arrivati a questo punto
potreste aver voglia di un caffè
e lo speaker non vedente
permette di uscire e andar
a prendere caffè tranquillamente.
(Applausi)
Solo una cosa vi chiedo:
l'ultimo che va via, che mi avvisi.
(Risate)
Questo inizio mi serviva un pochettino
per esorcizzare il momento,
perché non vi vedo
ma fate paura lo stesso.
Big data. Intelligenza collettiva.
Il tema del mio intervento mi
ha un po' spaventato.
Parliamo di ricerche di frontiera
dell'informatica e della matematica.
Come riuscirò in quindici minuti
a presentarle in modo tale
da non spaventare?
Ho deciso di farlo raccontandovele
veramente come le ho capite io.
Sono passati parecchi anni:
ero un neoassunto
e in un viaggio di lavoro
c'era un hostess molto simpatica
che mi ha accompagnato
al posto sull'aereo,
ad un certo punto mi ha detto:
"Posso darle qualcosa da leggere?"
"Qualcosa da leggere?
Sono un non vedente,"
però lo diceva in maniera
molto orgogliosa:
"Posso darle un giornale in braille."
Certo, qua siamo negli USA.
Un cieco? il giornale braille.
Certo, subito dopo ho capito
che tutto il mondo è paese
perché ho dato un'occhio alla data,
il giornale era di quattro anni prima!
(Risate)
Va be', sono anche appassionato di storia.
L'ho preso e in effetti ho fatto bene,
perché ho trovato un articolo
che era di quattro anni prima,
era coerente, ovviamente,
con la data del giornale.
Però mi era sfuggito forse all'epoca
che stava raccontando
una cosa mentre iniziavo l'avventura
nel mondo informatico.
E quell' articolo mi ha subito
messo in guardia.
Era la storia di un ragazzo
che si era laureato in fisica
con una tesi su come costruire
una bomba atomica.
in una scatola da scarpe.
Come, una bomba atomica
in una scatola da scarpe?
Incuriosito sono andato a vedere.
Il ragazzo diceva che tutta la ricerca
gli era costata 8 dollari
spesi su Internet.
Certo, mancava il combustibile,
l'uranio arricchito.
Ma quanto può costare l'uranio arricchito?
Non ne ho idea, un milione?
Dieci milioni di euro?
Ma voi non avete idea
di quanta gente qua fuori dispone
di 10 milioni di euro e di 8 dollari.
La bomba atomica è una bomba atomica.
La domanda spontanea era
ma chi è l'iodiota
che ha scritto su Internet
come costruire una bomba atomica?
È stata la risposta che col tempo ho dato
a questa domanda
che mi ha veramente spaventato,
perché quell'idiota non esiste.
Internet è l'ipertesto,
è il testo in potenza.
È il libro che contiene tutti i libri.
Alle mie spalle vedete
scorrere una pagina bellissima,
una delle pagine più belle
della letteratura mondiale,
quella in cui Borges spiega
la biblioteca di Babele,
ein basso vedete
lo scorrere di questo libro.
C'è tutto, è solo questione di tempo
e appare qualunque cosa.
Questo è l'ipertesto,
questo è Internet, è Tim Berners-Lee,
questo è tutto quanto riguarda
oggi il modello culturale.
Attenzione! Ma c'è qualcosa in più.
La potenza informatica e matematica
di questo strumento oggi è incredibile.
Ed è il big data, è qualcosa di più
dell'ipertesto, ovviamente.
Voi pensate il libro
che contiene tutti i libri.
Certo, è facilissimo pensare
che prima o poi
- in quella riga che vedete in basso -
appaiano i Promessi sposi,
la Divina Commedia, Pinocchio;
I Promessi sposi, un libro a caso.
"Quel ramo del lago di Como
che volge a mezzogiorno".
Dove vanno i big data?
Be', "Quel ramo del lago di Como
che volge a mezzogiorno",
alla parola 'quel'
segue la parola 'ramo'.
Quante volte nel romanzo?
E alla parola 'ramo'
segue la parola 'del';
quante volte nel romanzo?
E se io chiedessi, oggi, a un computer
di scambiare tra loro di posto
tutte le parole,
ma non casualmente,
cambiandole di posto
rispettando la distribuzione,
la percentuale delle coppie,
delle terne per un computer
è questione veramente di poco tempo.
Ma vi rendete conto che costruisco
un libro partendo da un altro libro?
È il sogno di Borges,
entrare nella biblioteca di Babele
e non perdere la ragione.
Io è da un po' che sto cercando i numeri
del Superenalotto di settimana prossima.
Ci sono, accipicchia!
È quello che ti fa rabbia.
Ma andiamo un pochettino
oltre a questo concetto.
Certo, il big data
effettivamente va un pochettino al di là.
Pensate: "Quel ramo del lago
di Como che volge a mezzogiorno";
'Quel', in quanti modi
può essere tradotto in cinese?
'Ramo', in quanti modi
E poi, www.facebook.com,
entro in un social network in Cina,
e vado a cercare,
tra quanto scrivono i cinesi,
frasi che hanno
la stessa distribuzione percentuale
della traduzione cinese delle parole
del romanzo del Manzoni.
Ottengo una traduzione
non matematica, non da un linguista,
ma una traduzione legata da quella
che si chiama intelligenza collettiva.
Chiedo se è possibile passare
a lucido successivo.
Devo lasciarlo là un pochettino,
perché richiede un momento
per poterlo acquisire.
Perché lo capiamo?
Questo lucido,
questa frase la capiamo
è una frase famosissima, ovviamente,
di solito a me serve per sottolineare
quell'elemento fondamentale
che c'è dietro a questo lucido
è che noi riusciamo a leggerlo
in virtù di innumerevoli capacità
che sottendono a questo strumento.
Sta di fatto che tutto questo
va sotto concetto
di intelligenza naturale.
L'informatica, da sempre, ha cercato
di emularla attraverso i concetti,
per quelli di voi che sono
un po'più vicini al mondo informatico
ne hanno senz'altro sentito parlare
dell'intelligenza artificiale.
I big data si basano invece
su un altro modello di intelligenza.
Cioè, quello che c'è dietro
a questo lucido può essere
di gran lunga cercare di emularne
il comportamento matematico è difficile.
È facilissimo attraverso proprio
l'intelligenza collettiva,
andare nei social network, e in rete,
a prendere
questa quantità infinita di dati
che scorrono;le telecamere,
trasmissioni televisive, email, sms;
sono tutta una serie di informazioni
che forniscono uno strumento
di elaborazione potentissimo.
Contengono delle regole d'uso
che permettono a un algoritmo matematico
di ricostruire la stessa abilità
con cui oggi percepite questo.
E questo non è vero
solo per il linguaggio parlato,
é vero anche per il linguaggio scritto,
un brano musicale, un filmato,
non solo sequenze di lettere,
sono comunque sequenze di 0 e di 1.
Quindi, nella biblioteca di Babele
ci sono anche tutti i film
che sono stati girati e tutti film
che verranno girati domani,
ma posso pensare anche agli aidoru
cioè questi cantanti virtuali
che in pubblicità costruiscono velocemente
prendendo come ispirazione,
ma come ispirazione matematica,
l'analisi percentuale
della distribuzione dei bit,
delle rock star del momento,
permettono di costruire
a costi bassissimi gingles pubblicitari.
Pensate a un'altra componente importante:
tutto questo c'è dietro il comportamento
di quel ragazzo che si muoveva
a caso su Internet
oggi i nostri ragazzi - avete senz'altro
sentito parlare dei makers -
non si muovono a caso su Internet,
si muovono a caso,
in un Internet che potenzia la realtà,
una realtà potenziate.
Fino a poco tempo fa, quando dovevo
stampare un documento
sul mio bel computer,
prendevo il mouse, spostavo l'icone
del documento sulla stampante,
bottone destro,
e produceva la stampa del documento.
Oggi, sto leggendo un sms,
appoggio il telefono sulla stampante,
e il mouse diventa la mia mano.
Ma voi pensate: questo meccanismo fatto
su Internet da migliaia di ragazzi
che disegnano pezzi, componenti,
li inviano a stampanti 3D.
Molto diverso. Molto di più,
ci sono vere e proprie fabbriche
a luci spente con strumenti
che sono in grado di -
tecnicamente si chiama plottare,
ma ritagliare nel metallo, nel legno,
stampare in 3D con polveri ceramiche,
delle fibre di vetro,
ricostruire tutto questo.
Veramente costruire un'internet
che non è fatta col mouse
ma è fatta veramente nella realtà
in cui siamo immersi tutti giorni.
Il problema grosso,
enorme, che salta fuori,
è, lo sapete tutti, lo vedete
anche sui giornali in questi giorni,
ma la riservatezza!
Cosa c'è dietro tutto questo!
Bene, qua è difficile accettarlo,
ma un po' il messaggio,
in generale, che la tecnologia è violenza
così come violenta è la cultura.
Con la cultura io recupero spazio
ma lo tolgo ad un altro.
È un equilibrio che si stabilisce.
Questa cosa è spiegata
molto bene nei testi di sociologia;
cioè come la tecnologia, pur violenta,
può essere veramente
trasformata in qualità di vita
con l'intelligenza collettiva
in una barzelletta che circola
tra i banchi di sociologia
qualche maligno dice che circola
anche tra i banchi politici,
è la barzelletta di un vecchietto
che scrive al figlio
che è stato messo in prigione:
"Ma cosa hai fatto, sciagurato,
ti sei è fatto arrestare.
Adesso per dissodare l'orto
non ho l'energia, come faccio a farlo?"
Arriva la risposta del figlio:
"Papà non toccare
l'orto, c'è la refurtiva!"
Subito dopo arriva la polizia
che butta per aria tutto l'orto.
Arriva la lettera al papà:
"Caro papà, data la situazione attuale,
era l'unico modo che avevo
per aiutarti a dissodare l'orto."
(Applausi)